my name is doc Crawley I'll give a
little bit of background I'm a senior
admin assistant over at Yale School of
Public Health and I work in the
Environmental Health Sciences Department
and my chair this year is going to teach
or has taught public health toxicology
which is EHS 503 and my I was given the
task to create everything for the
students in canvas so I had Jenn come
with over - Eph with us and sit down
with the chair because he's new to the
school new to teaching so and this is
new to canvas so I had to have a meeting
to have everybody there to see what is
what does he want to use canvas for and
how can we get there so we did have a
couple meetings actually with Jen when
we had some snafus in the beginning but
thanks to canvas we worked it out so I
have four bigger further copies of the
syllabus up here if you'd like to see it
cuz this only goes as you can see it
only goes to believe that April 7th and
the final is this week so when I first
took a look at this and I knew what
canvas has my thought was - he's having
lectures on Monday discussions on Friday
so I thought well why don't we create
modules that was my thinking so as soon
as the syllabus was done and finalized I
went into canvas and I created the
everything you see here in the modules
so I did lecture first with the date
title and on the syllabus he didn't put
in their lecture one - you know one
discussion - like that so for the
students I went in and I did you know
lecture one the title and who the
speaker is going to be he is himself and
he has guest speakers come in so that's
the way I created it in canvas and the
only way that you can see that is if I
show it to you good
so we just get
and here's the modules and as you can
see because when there was a
presentation I would be the one
uploading it to the students hopefully a
few days before the lecture that's what
he prefers sometimes it's the morning of
so I went in and as you can see
everything here I created you know
lecture one and then the discussion
after it and they would know that
lecture one you know is the first one
and what I chose to do we kind of he's
kind of left it up to me but what I
chose to do is not publish you know
until something was in there that's what
I chose to do and a couple pointers if
anyone in here is going to do that you
know we found out uploading PowerPoint
wasn't so great so we you have to take
the PowerPoint and convert it to PDF and
the students were able to get that
better so we found that out on the
beginning so we did that so everything's
PDF and the other thing I would publish
but I also on top of that have to send
announcements to the students I guess
they don't always see oh something's
there so now every time I publish I go
into announcements and I just send an
announcement we learned this throughout
and as you can see these are all my
announcements to them every time I
publish something I would let them know
hey it's here you know so they know when
it's available whether it's two days
before maybe the morning of so that's
what I utilized canvas for and that's
the way when I first looked at it that I
saw how to do it is to in my mind was to
put it in modules obviously before I
uploaded the syllabus to syllabus but
you could be in here I don't know how
many people have utilized any of these
discs but of course the syllabus is
there as you can see really that's
that's about it but those are my two
pointers and then go down
you know here like I would have like
there's a option in there to have
discussions indented a little bit so I
you know sometimes as presenters would
have their presentation and also papers
maybe so I just kind of make it in a way
when you look at it you understand it
it's kind of like looking at the
syllabus was my mind how I was looking
at it so that's what I utilize canvas
for so I don't know okay just to give
you an idea what it looks like and we'll
be doing this next spring - so yes
[Music]
correct my understanding is it is
through canvas but I believe so because
I know when although when I send an
announcement I do get an email that I
did it so I'll just leave that it does
extend out to zero analysis but every
person can control what notifications
they receive so if they feel like
somebody's posting way too many
announcements they can turn off
announcements so that they won't keep
getting those but the default setting is
that they would receive emails whenever
announcement is posted and I think that
was the problem is it's left up to the
students to have an announcement piece
on or off so some would say to the
faculty member I never got it unless I
thought I sent it you know and then we
were finding out who has it on who has a
lot you know you don't know so the best
thing is to just you know I just do an
announcement and you're supposed to all
get it so let's I hope they do and it
worked after we worked that out a little
bit so no consent you mentioned that you
have a problem the PowerPoint is that
because the powerpoints were a large
file size or did you have special
transitions in PowerPoint I just didn't
carry over probably both I'm thinking
the files are probably pretty big you
know I've seen you know because you're
you know the lectures an hour and a half
and you know I've seen you know 75 slide
you know you might have figures in there
and I think so I think that was a
problem
I really never found out but it's just
the easy quick
fix is just to do PDF and they were able
to download it that way it was much
better
so that's sure getting few guys in the
students about being able to navigate
this way rather than raisin might have
done it in the past when classes v2 was
a different instructor and he didn't
utilize it the way that this professor
does he just would put slides up there
and he didn't have guest lecturers and
it's very notice a very detailed which
is the way he was running it classes v2
was very easy a few slides here and
there's it was more easier with canvas I
did here we have a TA for the class and
they would like everything through
canvas they like canvas they like the
assignment piece or the paper piece
everything to be through canvas so we
decided to go that way rather than email
you know don't email me the final you
know I would whatever they're using the
TA is taking care of that piece and that
was facing back to her and then she came
back and so lust so what the PowerPoint
would be not what the resources are like
you can or people use the modules or
resources as well so you would and you
wouldn't put them in the other place
resources you mean papers or PDF oh yeah
I use it in modules because they would
give papers which were PDFs as part of
the dislike say it's a discussion and
it's two papers are going to discuss so
it's a PDF so I put it in that piece of
discussion you can see it in there and I
would upload the two papers and explain
the to page two files attached our part
of discussion today which is you know
kind of really a lot of information so
specifically they know what's going on
and like I said they seem to like that
piece it was a question here I think the
benefit to the students are putting all
with all of them everything they need
for that session they're reading the
link to the discussions if they're
submitting assignments powerpoints in
classes b2 they would need to go to one
place to find the files another place to
find the discussion this way they all
they need to do if you're in module and
we're not going to miss anything right
and my my thought was you know this one
week this week is a module you know he
has a lecture on Monday what's attached
to that underneath because it's Friday
is a discussion what's attached there so
they can look at it and I think pretty
much I put dates on all of them for me I
had to have the dates you know what's
going on April 3rd what's going on April
10th what's going on you know basically
what this is so that's the way I looked
at it I think it works so I'm going to
do saying next year unless I hear
different courses where maybe there's an
overlap of content you'd be able to just
copy the entire module from this course
you
I don't know you can definitely copy
content from any course that you can you
can copy as much or as little from
another course so you could do a full
course copy or you could be very
targeted and say I just want this
specific module or this specific file
from the file very pleased with the
controller thank you
[Music]